jacques au niveau mental
oui
comment
yvan attal
puis mon soir au soir c'est incroyable
quand même c'est que la dernière fois où
vous étiez sur ce plateau c'était pour
l'interprète un film de sydney pollack
avec nicole kidman
aujourd'hui vous revenez dans munich le
nouveau film de steven spielberg
mais la prochaine fois ça sera un film
de kubrick ou à kubrick je peux plus
j'espère pas du tout rencontrer sur
monsieur tout de suite so i want you are
here for the deal ou steven spielberg
movie et soyaux en fait cette alliance
est un crime for the night alors ça
c'est énorme quand même non bah oui
c'est énorme mais c'est vrai non mais
c'est vrai je m'attendais jure pas je
n'aurais jamais pu imaginer que je
tournerai avec steven spielberg et nous
donc c'est encore plus énorme quand tu
es dans la salle moi j'ai vu le film à
new york dans le coup quand tu vois ils
vont arriver un tipi amalric et doute
français en france d'aller tout il ya
quelques français quand même dans ce
film bernard menez n'a pas offert au
delà de tourner avec lui c'est jusqu en
plus c'était quand même vraiment
éclatant de travailler avec lui qui
m'avait alors donc le film s'appelle
l'unique l'histoire commence dans la
nuit du 5 septembre 1972 à munich
quand un commando de l'organisation
palestinienne septembre noir s'introduit
dans le village olympique force l'entrée
du pavillon israélien à ba2 occupants et
prend neuf autres en ôtage voilà et 21
heures plus tard ils sont tous morts à
ce moment-là gold amer qui dirige l'état
d'israël montrent une opération de
représailles et avner un jeune agent du
mossad interprété par eric bana prend la
tête d'une équipe de quatre hommes qui
va traquer à travers le monde
onze représentants de septembre noir
désigné comme responsable voilà alors
c'est un oeil pour oeil dent pour dent
un bas comment faire quand enfin bon
alors on va on va y aller
comment faire autrement quoi dire que
évidemment que spielberg raconte que
c'est c'est ça mène à rien puisqu'on est
quoi plus de trente ans après qu'on est
toujours dans la même situation mais
quand même ce que le film ne dit pas
c'est qu'à l'époque on pouvait pas
discuter
et avec les palestiniens c'est à dire
que les israéliens pouvaient pas
discuter avec les parisiens puisqu'il
était écrit dans la charte de l'olp et
de cette organisation parisienne qu'il
fallait détruire l'état d'israël
aujourd'hui c'est un peu différent mais
aujourd'hui il ya quand même des
organisations terroristes qui ne veulent
pas discuter avec israël non plus ça
veut dire le ramasse les israéliens
continuent leur politique de wade en
prenant parce que de toute façon il n'y
a pas d'autre solution quand on ne peut
pas s'asseoir avec ces gens là peau
pourparlers de paix donc comment faire
on peut pas se plier aux à la terreur
quoi enfin c'est pas possible